السلام عليكم ورحمه الله معكم محمد مزيما
لنتابع معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي
بايجاز وضمننا ابرز الاحداث زفاف في
العراق يتحول الى ماتم الاف الارمن ينزحون
من كنباخ السفير الفرنسي يغادر نيامه
واخبار اخرى لنتابعها نبدا نشرتنا من
محافظه نينوى والحدث الذي هز العراق اذ شب
حريق ضخم في قاعه افراح خلال اقامه حفل
زفاف توفي على اثره اكثر من 100 شخص واوصل
اكثر من 100 رئيس الوزراء العراقيه اعلن
الحداده في جميع انحاء البلاد لمده ثلاثه
ايام على ارواح الضحايا وتوعد بمحاسبه
المقصرين في حين اوقفت القوات الامنيه
العراقيه 14 شخصا بينهم مالك القاعه
تنضم الي الان مراسله الجزيره السير حكيم
يا مرحبا ستير
ما المعلومات التي لديك حول اسباب هذه
الفاجعه
محمد بحسب التحقيقات اسباب حريق قاعده
الحمدانيه عديده ويمكن القول ان جميع هذه
الاسباب تقع في بوتقه الاهمال والفساد
بدءا من منح رخص البناء للمنشات التي لا
تتوفر فيها شروط السلامه ومرورا بعدم جديه
اصحاب بعض القاعات والابنيه لتوفير انظمه
السلامه كمخارج الطوارئ وايضا اجهزه
لمكافحه الحرائق جميع هذه الاسباب ادت الى
نشوب حريق الحمدانيه وانتشاره بشكل كبير
وسريع هذا الحريق الذي خلف عشرات من
القتلى والاصابات داخل القاعه اما نتيجه
اختناقهم او تعرضهم للاحتراق شكرا
نذهب الان الى تطورات ملف كراباخ حيث
اعلنت السلطات الارمينيه في الاقليم حلا
ما يعرف بجمهوريه كنباخ ومؤسساتها اعتبارا
من مطلع العام المقبل وتقول ان نح الف شخص
عبروا الحدود الى ارمينيا من الاقليم
ليقتصر وجود من بقي من ارمن الاقليم في
فحسب رئيس الوزراء الاربعينيه اعلن في
بيان مغادرتها جميع الارمله الاقليم في
غضون ايام معتبرا ان ما يجري في الاقليم
هو تطهير عرقي وتهجير في المقابل اتهمت
الخارجيه الاذربيجانيه البيانات بالتضليل
المجتمع الدولي عبر النشر روايات لا تمت
للواقع بصله على حد وصفها ينضم الي الان
الباحث في العلاقات الروسيه الاطلسيه
والقوقاز الدكتور باسل الحاج جاسم
مرحبا دكتور باسل في خضم هذه هي التطورات
في اقليم كراباخ ما السيناريوهات المتوقعه
في تقديرك
الواضح وبحسب تطورات الاوضاع الميدانيه
داخل كرباخ فالامور تتجه نحو طي صفحه ازمه
كهرباء والتي استمرت لاكثر من 30 عام منذ
بدايه انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي مطلع
التسعينيات وخلفت هذه الازمه عشرات الالاف
من القتلى ومئات الالاف من اللاجئين من
الطرفين الارمني والاذربيجاني مع اعلان
رئيس الجمهوريه التي اطلق عليها كارباخ
واعلنت من جانب واحد حل هذا الكيان مع
مطلع العام المقبل يعني صفحه هذا الملف
سيتم طيرها لتفتح صفحات لازمات اخرى سواء
داخل ارمينيا او في العلاقات الارمنيه
الروسيه او اقليميا ودوليا في ظل
الاستقطاب الحاد حول منطقه جنوب القوقاز
في ظل اشتعال الازمه الاوكرانيه والانشغال
روسيا بها شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور فيصل من
كارباخ الى النيجر وبعد ان كانت باريس
رافضه لمواصفته بالرضوخ لمطالب قاده هي
الانقلاب سفير فرنسا في النيامي يعود الى
بلاده بعد شهر من مطالبه المجلس العسكري
بالمغادره الخارجيه الفرنسيه تقول ان سحب
السفير ومغادره القوات الفرنسيه تم بعد
اتصال هاتفي اجره ماكرون مع الرئيس محمد
بازو في وقت لاحق اغلق المجلس والعسكري في
النيجر المجله الجويه امام جميع الطائرات
هي الفرنسيه في تعميم نشرته وكاله الامن
والملاحه الجويه في افريقيا دعوني اذهب
الان الى الزميل عمر الذي يوضح لنا كيف
سيؤثر اغلاق النيجر المجال الجوي امام
الطائرات الفرنسيه على شركات الطيران هناك
مرحبا عمر اهلا محمد
الفرنسيه وصفت هذا الاغلاق اغلاق النيجر
ومجالها الجوي بانه ضرب قاسيه على الشركات
الفرنسيه هناك لماذا لو نرى هنا على
الخريطه هذه هي فرنسا هنا
وهذه النيجر هنا ما المشكله الان بعد
اغلاق النيجر مجالها الفرنسيه ان ليبيا
هنا والسودان اصلا مغلق مجال الجوي بسبب
صراعات هناك فبالتالي نشا عندنا خط طويل
مغلق امام الطائرات الفرنسيه التي تريد ان
تذهب الى الجنوب الافريقي دول الجنوب
افريقيا والوسط الافريقي فالان اصبح
امامها مسارين اما مسار ان تسلك عند دول
الغرب الافريقي من هنا الى هذه البقعه او
انت تاتي من جهه البحر الاحمر شرق القاره
لتصل الى الى
الدول دول جنوب افريقيا او الوسط الافريقي
وهذا طبعا بطبيعه الحال سيؤدي الى زياده
في الوقت وزياده في الوقود وما يؤدي الى
خساره اقتصاديه حقيقه
ونضع في عين الاعتبار ان الخطوط الجويه
الفرنسيه هي المهيمنه على على رحلات التي
تذهب من اوروبا الى
افريقيا شكرا جزيلا يعطيك الف عافيه شكرا
على التوضي الى البحرين اذا اعلنت قوه
الدفاع عن مقتل اربعه من عناصرها بينهم
ضابط وضابط صفط جراء هجوم حوثي بطائرات
مسيره على مواقعها عند الحدود الجنوبيه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه واستنكرت
الاخيره ما حدث وصفه مياهو بالهجوم الغادر
من جهته قلل المبعوث الامي الى اليمن انه
تواصل مع جميع الاطراف للحث على ممارسه
اقصى درجات ضبط النفس في هذا الوقت الحالي
نختم نشرتنا من فرنسا وفصل جديد من فصول
التضييق على المسلمين حيث اعلنت وزيره
الرياضه الفرنسيه ايميلي كاستيرا منع
الحجاب على الرياضيات الفرنسيات المشاركات
في الاولمبياد القادم الذي تحتضنه فرنسا
العام المقبل مؤكده ان موقف بلادها واضح
جدا في هذا المجال وهو التمسك بنظام
علماني يطبق بشكل صارم في مجال الرياضه في
المقابل رفضت هيئه تابعه للامم المتحده
الحظر وانتقد ناشطون القرار معتبرين ان
حضور ماكرون قداسا لباب الفاتيكان ينافي
مبدا الدوله بالحياد الديني ويرون ان
القرارات ضد المسلمين هي من ازدواجيه
المعايير المغردون التفاعلوا مع هذا الحظر
الجديد في فرنسا لنقرا لكم بعض التغريدات
يوسف الباك يقول اذا لم يكن هذا تمييزا ضد
الرياضيين الفرنسيين المسلمين فما هو اما
دكتور عدلي فيقول حريه
وكرامه والمراه تنتهك في بلد يرفع شعار
الحريه بالتاكيد يمكنكم المشاركه في هذا
الموضوع ومواضيع اخرى ضمن التعليقات
اشكركم على متابعتي نلتقي بحول الله
الاسبوع المقبل اينما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم
بكل خير
[موسيقى]